[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it is said that in the final days of
planet Earth see it does not contain
Vogons building a hyperspatial express
route everyone had bad dreams are you
sure you don't have to wait till the
final days of Earth for all of us to
have bad dreams got that covered in 2022
buddy wait does that mean these are the
final days of Earth was this a prophecy
this is like when I read the book of
Revelation grade school and was sure
that my teacher was the Antichrist
you're still on my radar Mrs Snyder I'm
watching you oh and of course narration
opening on a shot of Earth from space
with an ominous narrator speaking of the
end of days was setting the Sci-Fi tone
quite nicely so why does it suddenly
feel like I'm watching a deleted scene
from Love Actually they forgot the
homeless except for one it appears that
the one also forgot and is now
remembering and I know that seems like a
semantic argument but I'd like to refer
you to the YouTube channel you have
apparently mistakenly clicked on this is
the kind of over candling that
infuriates me are you trying to melt the
upper candles From Below is the Ambiance
that much better with 14 candles as
opposed to five the wax industry must be
put on trial preferably in a 14 part
miniseries led by Colin Baker also whose
bright idea was it to put so many
flammable foe past the fire
extinguishers next to a bunch of kids
won't somebody please think of the kids
but also also kids they call it the
legend of the blue box title for my very
legitimate Avatar adult film somehow
makes it into the episode he smoked the
demon then disappeared I know the
British are known for being painfully
polite but at what point in this strange
story does Wilfred feel justified in
asking and what the bloody hell is any
of that got to do with me Governor
there's no such thing as coincidence
accidents
can you imagine saying that in meaning
it on this show
oh that wouldn't make my Christmas
pulling a Batman on a passerby you just
gave an unwanted history lesson too it's
just rude is what it is
excessive masturbating actual footage
from my very legitimate Avatar adult
film somehow makes it into this episode
so well
using the phrase so where were we to
give yourself an excuse to vomit blatant
Exposition for a few minutes in case
some idiot only watches the Christmas
specials I show the phosphorus Carousel
of the great Magellan gestat people who
brag about vacations they didn't bother
inviting you to good Queen bet let me
tell you her nickname is no longer
yeah sorry I'm late that's getting late
you know how it is noodle bro give me
ten tickles last time I was here you
said my song would be ending soon
and I'm in no hurry for that the doctor
gets super somber about the youth's call
for this ends than his back cracking
jokes to the Ute about locking the
Tardis like an earth car in 10 seconds
and I'm just not sure I can handle these
oot swings you will join I don't know my
half-eaten carbonara dribbling friend
sounds kind of like a cult and not the
cool ones where everyone gets naked the
boring kind with the Mindless chanting
and an often promised but never realized
edit button what about Donna is she safe
you should not have delayed obligatory
the doctor can go back in time and
protect people and change things when he
can but can't when he can't sin delayed
he literally has all the time in the
universe I think he can make sure that
Donna Noble has been saved we see so
much but understand little the Stephen
Moffett years I can show you
expositional mind-milled flashbacks
flash melds positioned the master is
dead and yet you did not see wait the
doctor started out having to explain the
story to the discount Biff because they
didn't know it and now they've taken
over the explaining to him the stuff he
doesn't know who's expositioning who
here or is it who's expositioning who
who's expositioning who whom is
expositioning whom I say and these
events from years ago threatened to
destroy this future and the present and
the past so pretty much all the time
then right geez you think spaghetti
Cthulhu here would learn to be a little
more succinct you're gonna delay the
doctor again the end of time itself roll
ude Marshall's I swear if David Tennant
runs much more in this episode he'll be
in danger of getting sued for copyright
infringement by Tom Cruise tonight Mrs
he returns thinking you can save an
ailing show by bringing back a beloved
actor to play the same major role
several years later even though the
conclusion was resolved clearly and with
finality glad the show learned its
lesson there and won't be pulling that
one again you bore his imprint
we need it and yet we still dragged you
all the way out here for the ceremonial
expositioning for reasons that we can't
tell you also so because he kissed her
lips at some point in the past never
mind how long ago somehow you can take a
wiping of those lips to resurrect him
was there a will never wash my face
claws in the prenup who wrote this
[ __ ] book Never Dying Never Dying
Never Dying never dying I know right
thankfully everyone here knew the proper
never explained procedure to make sure
that there are never really stakes in
the show ever again right and all this
time your disciples have prepared
but so have we and yet I waited all the
way through the ceremonial expositioning
before over monologuing about it for
reasons that I can't tell you but my
calculate the opposite hey Bill uh my
daughter Lucy's been locked up in some
sort of covert prison but she managed to
let me know that her dead time guy
psychotic ex-husband might come back if
his followers can make this here potion
if I send some over to you do you think
you could well how did she say that
again uh calculate the opposite oh sure
Tommy I'll just throw it in my what's
the opposite of this potion calculator
and have you something in three shakes
of a snake's tongue and I hope that old
time guy ex-husband thing works out for
thanks Bill knew I could count on you
hey tell Susan I hope her gout gets
better someone survived that's not
footage of someone escaping a fire this
guy's just playing an NES game he
thought we wouldn't notice but we did
but he's tall and Finn wears a brown
suit Wilford gathers a Bus full of
admittedly adorable geriatric people to
search London for a man he doesn't have
a picture of who could be anywhere in
time and space now that's optimism I got
locked inside one of them August bank
holiday 1962. well you misbehaving
Minnie I certainly was why hey of all
the possible will show ideas the fact
that we've never gotten made the
misbehaving Mrs mini spin-off is
probably the most sinful but that's on
HBO and just watch the Emmys roll in
I'm not actually sure how that's
possible because you are chewing up the
scenery with every single line delivery
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this heavy breathing and banging goes on
for all of the not the good kind of
heavy breathing and banging sometime if
he can jump like this why bother running
at all does the ability have a cool down
period or something
can we talk about this skeleton effect
for a second look we all know part of
the charm of the Doctor Who Universe has
been the Lo-Fi effects but every time
this happens I just think of they live
and unless Roddy Piper comes back to
life to play a role this is not a
reference that bodes well for you Tiana
what did I tell you about limiting your
running believe me you really don't want
to be on the business end of a Tom
Cruise running lawsuit remember the Tom
Cruise sins Channel we had no that's
because we got a summons to court and
had to shut the whole thing down some of
the writers for that channel didn't make
it out alive it was awful and her
neighbor saw this man heading east so a
friend of a friend saw the police box
and then called and told her the man she
was looking for was just heading east in
many somehow took that to mean head to
the junkyard listen I'll buy time
traveling police boxes and Squid aliens
but I draw the line at unbelievable
tracking it's actually in our top 3
three sin rules right after say skip at
least once a video but before all
employees must wash hands before
returning to sinning come on
give me one to smile let people
damn it you're British you should love
that [ __ ] keep smiling
is that your hand Minnie
good boy
misbehaving many of the Menace makes
malicious move to mash mr's Maximus
meanwhile the misguided manuscript
makers momentarily mistake madame's
molestation from Earth who are you no
who are you oh we keep on meeting wealth
over and over again like something's
still connecting us the cold Riders
David and in this show they conveniently
connect a lot of things everything I
hadn't died some new man goes sauntering
away disrespecting Matt Smith is some
new man when he would go on to star in
such movies as Terminator Genesis Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies morbius and
the morbius re-release I thought it was
better
but I did some things it went wrong
David Tennant is so amazing in this role
I almost wish they would nah never mind
oh well take your sin off you genius you
look wouldn't she make you laugh again
good old Donna Wilfred he just said if
she ever remembers him she'll burn up
and die what part of that is so hard for
you to understand and she's getting
married you want the doctor to just run
in at the last second and Rachel Green
it all and so it came to pass that the
players took their final places making
ready the events that were to come uh
yeah that's called chronology that's how
stories work characters do thing an
advanced narrative until it reaches a
conclusion man [ __ ] like us come
along to nitpick that conclusion hits
the circle of life or something anyway
say smarter stuff also breaking into mid
episode narration for no purpose other
than reminding us you have a narrator so
we don't forget about it before the big
narrator reveal at the end while his
savior looked upon the Wilderness that's
not the Wilderness that's another
junkyard Wilderness has trees and grass
don't you have to pass some sort of
narrator into entrance exam to get your
narrator certification of the final day
Timothy Dalton you have the best doctor
and the best bond in your show and
you're just giving us a small tease now
when you get Timothy Dalton you make
room for more Timothy Dalton so what
exactly is he the master of because it
sure isn't hitting targets did he attend
the Stormtrooper School of aiming
superpowers I don't understand and
didn't realize time Lords possessed also
my favorite part of this whole electric
OK Corral standoff is that we have
exactly zero idea about what any of this
means or what any of it is doing to the
doctor confusion is the best it's mine
it's mine it's my turn
as far as any circus Impressions go this
isn't the worst but it's not the best
either so here's a sin for not quite
hitting the Golem bar no participation
trophies here at TV since holy [ __ ] you
thought I was mad John Sims plays a
character in The Otts who along with the
audience has no idea if he's actually
insane cliche
wait a second the doctor just took a
giant blast of lightning to the chest
and was able to run across the junkyard
with no problem now he gets one hit from
behind and he's out like a light what'd
you hit him with it was stronger than a
blast of lightning it's the sort of
thing she finds rather
I swear every single actor in the
special had to do an intense six-week
training course at the bond villain
school for melodramatic line reads
thinking an unsecure suitcase under the
bed is a safe place to store a gun what
is he coming no it's nothing nothing the
doctor's asking you if you've seen
anything strange with a crazed look in
his eyes and you consider a special
bulletin delivered to you by name on
your Telly nothing you can come with me
oh you're not leaving me with her dad
this works
right now you know a great way to keep
someone you love from having their brain
exploded by a secret they should know
because it isn't running outside and
yelling about the thing they're not
supposed to know about stay relative to
the master within the causal Nexus
understand
and not a word don't worry we didn't
understand him either here's two cents
for thinking that making up time slash
space words would distract us from the
plot hole slash [ __ ] excuse me sir
if I could check the basement we're
getting fluctuation on the power chords
of course Miss Adams if you could bring
the calibration statistics these two are
obviously making up an excuse to leave
the room which means they're either
trying to sneak in a quick shag or chat
about secret plans and the fact that no
one in this room even suspects this is
ridiculous who is he no master is he
foreign
look as far as dinosaur Impressions go
this one isn't the worst but it's not
the best either you need some tiny
tomatoes to really do it right I should
carried some Burns as a result of an
accident when she was a child but down
her left side if you could
proof is this the master did he know her
before here let me prove to you that I
have a finger regenerating machine that
regenerated the middle finger on both of
my hands see I want her never to die my
gift so you don't want to use it on
yourself you you just want your daughter
to live forever carrying the death of
her father who could have been by her
side but chose not to have you read any
stories about Immortals You Know It
usually sucks the most about living
forever seeing your loved ones die just
watch Highlander dude she would be
Immortal that's meant to be his daughter
right because this relationship feels a
little
thronesy better get to work you have a
dangerous cannibal who can shoot
lightning from his hands and the only
thing keeping him in place is a Pet
Smart collar with a thin leash that book
said he's a billionaire she's got his
own private Army did he even have time
to read the book he opened it complained
and then the doctor showed up Wilfred is
a liar greatest Generation my
regenerated middle finger threads of
Harmony
for multiple overshots triplicate ooh
have the split slots congealed did you
check and see if the coaxial links had
parasinked with the thrust manifold did
you check the dampness of the corridor
uptake oh my Lord she's a cactus that's
spacest skeletal whatever you're calling
him what's he doing up there thinking
these two aliens will understand your
Masters of the Universe reference and as
soon as it's working we can transport it
to the shade why does it have to be
working for you to transport it wait is
it built of plot tanium alloy boys
Barack Obama will lead us all into a new
age of prosperity Barack Barack who the
[ __ ] is that it's Barack Obama as in any
American news anchor who mispronounced
the current president's name must have
been living under a Barack like that was
ever gonna happen was he just waiting
for the doctor to make a grand entrance
why wait this long to blow your
restraints off I feel like the president
would have turned away or simply excused
himself and left the stage literally
anything more subtle than standing on
the podium with his face in his hands
like a child on timeout 50 seconds and
counting it will take exactly 74 seconds
listen if that box can keep the master
plan from taking effect on Wolf there is
no way a cell phone signal is getting
through there's a fight here in my head
well yeah where else would you expect it
to be good grief he's turned everyone
into novelty bobble heads truly the
worst of all novelty Christmas gifts
monster breaking news I'm everyone the
final two minutes of this episode will
just be varying versions of this same
exact reveal it's like when my uncle
Steve finds out a new fact about his
favorite movie and starts every
conversation for the next month with did
you know the Velociraptor noises in
Jurassic Park or the sounds of tortoises
there is only the master race I just
cringe so hard three of my vertebrae
shattered so here's one sin for each
laughing more laughing even more
laughing Climax and so it came to pass
on Christmas day that the human race did
cease to exist most of the human race
cease to exist Donna and Wilfred are
still human remember gonna be careful
with those infinitive statements
narrator designing your meeting Hall
like the galactic Senate from Star Wars
was a dumb idea in Star Wars and it's a
dumb idea here look at all this wasted
space Also though now in this episode
with some more random mumbo-jumbo about
time ending and be no closer to
understanding what that actually means
before cliffhanging us fortunately for
you they finish the second part the next
week unfortunately for you we will not
see you next year suckers
I'd like to take his his face off
I knocked it like a car
that it's funny
no you are a sad strange little man and
you have my pity
but something more is happening doctor
the master is part of a greater design I
am surrounded by snakes and pink morons
for his name is
the most ever
why ten thousand years will give you
such a crick in the neck take a look at
this
[Music]
guy guys
stop running away from me like some fool
of a Moody School child I just don't
like you no more you do like me you
don't like me yesterday
there never was a story
[Music]
Bishop Juliet and her roaming